the big breaking news is that Paramount
and Warner Brothers might be talking
about merging it's not breaking news if
you're a regular sidetracker though
because I told you a month ago welcome
to Sidra your SciFi TV and Movie Channel
when this news dropped last night that
Paramount and Warner Brothers have
actually had sitdown conversations
already to discuss the possibility of
merging I was immediately on the
WhatsApp group that I used to talk to
several of my regular sources and I
asked who knew what now I as I've
already said was told about a month ago
about this possibility that Warner
Brothers were looking for a more
long-term partner now initially I
believe that this was actually going to
be a potentially acquisition of the
Paramount Studio lots and maybe some
elements of their IP but not all of it
but actually now it's coming out that is
they're actually looking at more of a
merger this would would be Paramount and
Warner Brothers just basically coming
together and creating one company
similar to what Warner Brothers did with
Discovery their debt which is
significant would be combined and they
would be able to work together in the
future now I'm going to tell you what
that would look like in a couple of
minutes but first of all I'm going to
tell you about the source that I
originally told me about this and a
source that I've now been able to speak
to because this is going to be exclusive
nobody else knows this so the source
that originally came to me about a month
ago was telling me that this might
happen it isn't the direct source this
was a friend of a friend situation but
that Source has now been able to put me
in touch with the original source and
I've literally just got off the phone to
them they are actually directly working
for one of the companies doing
consultation work for Warner Brothers
and Paramount right now what is that
consultation work well this idea has
been bouncing between Warner Brothers
and parents out for a while I'm being
told anything up to 6 months since the
first actual consultation work began now
why is this all kept very hush hush if
things like this aren't kept secret the
companies could actually be accused of
stock market manipulation um basically
trying to drive their stock market price
up so these sort of things have to be
kept quite secret until um you get to a
certain point I'm actually being told
this was leaked now because this is a
bit further along than we're being told
and this actually is pretty much going
to happen and it's been leaked because
it's a week before Christmas and pretty
much Hollywood is dead right now I spoke
to the source they're at home I spoke to
a couple of other people they've all
shut up shop and gone home for for the
holidays basically so that is why it's
been released at this
point so what is the consultation work
again so they're basically looking at
all the math to figure out whether this
is a good idea so on this the surface
this isn't a good idea on the surface
these two companies own a crapload of
money and don't necessarily have the
market share to support that debt got my
notes any major company really doesn't
want to have a debt that is more than
about 40% of their market share by that
I mean they don't necessarily want debt
that is more than 40% of what the
company is worth so Warner Brothers debt
as of the close of last quarter
is
43.5 billion a big chunk of that is
coming from the acquisition or the
merger of Discovery um I think it went
from about 15 or 12 billion something
like that to this 43 billion Mark round
when that happened their market share is
28.4 billion that means their um debt
ratio is close to
150% paramounts debt currently stands at
15.6 billion and that is a slight
increase because they had actually got
it under 14 billion at one point um but
their market share is only 10.3 billion
again though that means that their debt
ratio is around
150% if these companies merge and they
keep the debt as is and they actually
keep their market share though they're
going to be looking at something in the
region of $60 billion worth of debt and
a market share of maybe 40%
so it's not really going to
help but according to the person I've
been speaking to this is being
considered a very good idea by Warner
Brothers and by Paramount why because
when these companies merge they can
massively cut costs so what their work
is being done at the moment is they're
looking at what assets both of these
companies own and what assets could they
merge one of the things that um has been
talked about is sort of like merging
sort of the Animation Studios that both
these companies control into one site
and they estimate that could save
anything up to a billion dollars um or
or generate because they'd be able to
sell real estate basically they could
sell the old Studio
spaces also Paramount and Warner
Brothers are two of the biggest Studio
space owners in California so they could
maybe sell off sections of their current
Studio space but because they're working
together they wouldn't actually maybe
lose any capacity to produce so again
they could make significant savings the
biggest area they can save on savings
though and this could actually generate
Savings of anything up to $ 1.5 billion
doar a year is by merging their
streaming services now this comes into
another big part that I was told a
couple of months ago that Netflix are
actually talking to HBO about absorbing
Max into Netflix now what I've been told
is that those conversations are still
happening but they've actually moved on
a little bit the idea being that Netflix
will actually manage HBO Max streaming
service and Paramount plus that Netflix
would use their software their servers
etc etc they've got a big deal with the
Amazon server network is it WPS I think
it's called um and they've actually been
able to massively decrease their costs
through this deal um in the last 3 years
or so Netflix have actually gone from
losing money to making money I'm pretty
sure they're the only streaming service
that are so Warner Brothers and
Paramount are looking at Netflix and
going well they know how to do it so
let's let them do it so there would
still be apparently three channels there
would still be Netflix there would still
be Paramount plus and there would still
be Max but then Netflix who will manage
all three will then offer those three
channels as sort of a super bundle so
you can either get Netflix retener HBO
Max retener and Paramount Plus retener
or you can get all three for like 20
quid it's that going to it's going to be
that kind of
deal again server space is the number
one area where they'll save money but
also just admin costs and things because
again Netflix will be doing it all so
they would absorb that but serice space
um Disney got rid of a bunch of TV shows
a little while ago and it saved them
$500 million a year
immediately Paramount and HBO are
basically looking at the same sort of
thing but they actually estimate they
could save 1.5 billion a year that is
massive consing that is $1.5 billion
every year that can be moved into paying
off debt instead now the merger will
cost money there will be jobs lost there
will be expenses that go with this type
of deal and they are actually expecting
their debt overall to probably increase
by around 5 to 10% initially now we are
there talking about billions of dollars
billions of dollars that then will be
immediately funneled into paying down
the debt as quickly as possible
something shareholders in both
businesses are very keen for them to do
so what would this actually look like
well I'm being told Warner Brothers want
to absorb the studio space the IP that
Paramount own and basically the film and
TV side they do not want to absorb CBS
CBS would be separated and potentially
sold off in the future so what we would
end up with is Paramount Warner Brothers
Discovery Paramount plus Max and Netflix
being available in this super bundle a
lot of real estate potentially being
sold by both of these companies as they
streamline and merge many of their
current working things so instead of
doing things twice and only do it once
you need a lot less office space things
like that and just just practical things
like that that they can get rid of and
save money on and
sell and a plan to drive the debt down
significantly over the next 10 years now
apparently some of the consultations
with the banks are suggesting that they
could get to around this 30 to 40% debt
ratio I.E their debt is by around 30 to
40% of their overall market share
currently that would mean their debt had
to drop to
around1 or 12
million assuming their market share
didn't increase in the same time so
basically they would have to wipe out
$30 billion worth of debt over a 10-year
period but the estimates are saying that
that is actually feasible and what the
shareholders are
demanding now apparently according to my
source he's saying that it's going to be
painful but
doable what does this mean for
television and Movie Zone things it
probably won't mean a great deal of
difference Warner Brothers will continue
to make their IP Paramount will continue
to make their IP they'll just be working
together in lots of ways I don't
actually think this will be like when
Amazon bought MGM they bought it
outright and merged those companies and
created Amazon MGM Studios but this was
a very different situation it was a tech
giant buying a studio for resp ECT and
for the skills Etc that came with a
studio of nearly a century old these are
two massive Studios that are having
serious financial difficulties coming
together to resolve those financial
difficulties but will the regulator even
allow this now the Federal Trade
Commission will have to ratify this deal
they were not happy about the deal
between Amazon and MGM they were not
happy about the deal for Disney and fox
but the chances are this will spend
about a year in committee there will be
a lot of shouting a lot of yelling a lot
of backdoor deals like there were
between Amazon and MGM when that was
going through and it'll get ratified
it'll probably take about 12 to 18
months though because it is such a big
deal similar sort of time scale to the
Disney and fox merger probably so guys
that is everything we know right now
this is a massive deal it is really a
big deal and I'd love to know what you
think about it this is merging of debt
to try and pay that debt off in the long
run do you think it'll work and do you
actually think that we could get maybe
some better products if these two
companies streamlined focused and maybe
try to get us some better product at the
end and maybe try to get us some better
movie on the screen and increase their
market share Maybe by focusing they can
do that what do you think get to the
comments if you are new to the Channel
please like subscribe hit that Bell
notification it really helps us that you
never miss any of our videos also you
get to patreon.com for/ citrek where
most of our new videos premere first and
you get to see them without the adverts
you lucky bunnies also go over to
c.co where when I get time I write
articles based on a lot of our videos
and I try to add a little bit more
information for you to digest go check
it out as always please stay safe merry
Christmas and I'll see you next
[Music]
time